Jim Morrison, of the 60's rock group The Doors,
was the first rock star to be arrested on
stage.
For one day in 1998, Topeka, Kansas, renamed
itself “ToPikachu” to mark Pokemon's U.S.
debut.
The U.S. bought Alaska for 2 cents an acre
from Russia.
In the 1700s, "macaroni" was a slang term
for a fashionable man.
98% of people in Japan are cremated.
California has issued 6 drivers licenses to
people named “Jesus Christ.”
The top of the Eiffel Tower leans away from
the sun, as the metal facing the sun heats
up and expands.
It can move as much as 7 inches.
In 14th-century England, children were baptised
in cider.
Australian soldiers used the song “We're
Off to See the Wizard” as a marching song
in WWII.
NASA estimates that the near-Earth asteroid,
Eros, contains 20 billion tonnes of gold.
During the 17th Century, the Sultan of Turkey
ordered his whole harem of women to be drowned
and replaced with a new one.
In ancient Egypt, servants were covered in
honey so as to attract flies away from pharaoh.
Christmas Day is the number one day for heart
attacks worldwide, followed by December 26th
and then New Year's Day.
The female lion does 90% of the hunting for
the pride.
Icelanders consume more Coca-Cola per Capita
than any other nation.